drops a bomb on the clippers
johnson can have to talk to ty lue about
scheming against some of those threes
that's the fourth one
for donovan mitchell george inside
cousins underneath the bucket
had it blocked by gobert and the jazz
had numbers
though bears wide open they couldn't get
it to him
ingles with a step back three got it
salt lake city let me hear you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
seems mark you just touched on this when
we were at break you want to close
quarters strong
they were playing collide couldn't get
the stick back
from point blank range critical stops
and clutch shooting thus far in the last
couple ingles
got it
and every time the team with the best
record in the regular season
has responded in kind
there's a reason this team finished with
the best record but there's the snooze
button you're talking
somebody might want to check mr ingles i
know it's been a little bit of a
struggle in the playoffs
but that dude was on fire from three and
he is one of the most
underrated i almost said something i
should
uh trash talkers
yes these first team all trash